cécile de oliveira avocate de la famille
de steve bonsoir cécile de oliveira
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france on en vient à cette marche
blanche dont on parlait tout à l'heure
avec un adage abderrazak 1 deux ans jour
pour jour après le décès de steve c'est
important ce type dommage pour vous
c'est important surtout pour la famille
pour la mémoire de steve et pour les
amis de steve qui sont nombreux pour moi
l'avocat s'était mouvement bien sûr mais
c'est d'abord un hommage qui vient pour
les proches et pour ceux qui aiment
steve mailhac and is you et puis c'est
un hommage qui vient rappeler aux
pouvoirs publics à quel point la mort de
ce jeune homme est importante
est-ce que vous ne traînez pas des
récupérations politiques on sait que le
rassemblement qui rassemble pour le
moment peu de monde mais a été annulé
pardon interdit à 20h30
rassemblement à l'appel d'un groupuscule
d'extrême gauche c'est ce type de choses
que vous craignez une récupération
politique autour de la mort de steve
ballmer de steve mayacoeur ni sow est
une mort qui a été presque tout de suite
mort politique et cette affaire
judiciaire est aussi un objet politique
donc je suis consciente de ces enjeux là
moi je ne rentre pas dans la
politisation de cette histoire j'ai un
travail à faire l'un travaille pour la
famille de steve mailhac à nice au un
travail pour steve majaka ni sow est en
revanche qu'il faut que je sois
consciente des enjeux politiques de
cette affaire
en tout cas beaucoup de ses soutiens
dénoncent des mensonges on entendu ce
jeune homme tout à l'heure caroline
interviewé par nadège abderrazak il
dénoncé beaucoup de mensonges autour de
steve canis os que
vous partagez ce diagnostic alors moi je
suis avocate et j'ai un devoir de
contrôler ma ma parole
parce que c'est l'intérêt de la famille
de steve manyaka michaud que je puisse
être gardé toute crédibilité de
l'institution judiciaire ce qui est
certain c'est que le rapport de l'igpn
du 16 juillet 2010 neuf comportaient un
élément absolument essentiel qu'ils
étaient faux et sur l'heure à laquelle
le téléphone de cils maniaque addition
aurait borné pour la dernière fois
cet élément était faux il visait à des
douanes et la police est bien évidemment
je rapport de l'igpn m'était apparu tout
de suite je m'étais exprimé sur le sujet
comme vraiment rédigé à la hâte et
probablement sur commande
effectivement le parquet de rennes a
tranché il ya trois jours à l'enquêté a
établi qu'il était tombé dans la loire
dans le temps d'intervention de la
police et non pas avant qu'elle ait
clairement et ce actuellement puisque on
le rappelle vous est avocate et juris
qu'elle est factuellement la conclusion
vous en tirez vous verrez donc l'élément
essentiel c'est la chronologie pour
établir l'infraction d'homicide
involontaire
on a la notion maintenant de façon
certaine que le téléphone portable de
steven haqqani sceaux s'est éteint à
4h39 au moment en quelques minutes après
tombé dans la loire
il est resté dans la poche du jean de
stévia camusso on à la notion que la
charge policière elle commence à 4h24 et
que la plupart des jeunes qui tombent
dans la loire des jeunes gens qui sont
en train de faire la fête tombe
quasiment en même temps que ce film avec
annie chaud donc on a vraiment une
concordance qui permet à ce qu'on
appelle un lien de causalité entre la
fête des jeunes
la chute dans la loire
immédiatement consécutive ont lâché de
grenade lacrymogène qui sont absolument
beaucoup trop nombreuses qui sont par
ailleurs lâché à un endroit extrêmement
dangereux que je suis en bord de loire
pour vous c'est déjà une forme de
reconnaissance de la justice ah bah pour
moi cette expertise qu'on attendait
depuis plusieurs mois elle est
absolument essentiel moi j'ai jamais
douté que la justice allait faire le
maximum pour rétablir la vérité
à la suite de style vraiment victime à
la connaissons moi j'en ai jamais douté
que la justice aujourd'hui quelles
suites au dossier
aujourd'hui je suis le dossier bien des
convocations
d'abord deux policiers ça fait très
important pour la place de steve m'a
décalé sow et puis d'autres personnes
maires préfets certains seront mis en
examen la famille de steve magniez
qualifions espère que les policiers
seront mis en examen et puis
l'instruction va se poursuivre on est
vers un procès qui vient te leur a
peut-être dans trois ou quatre ans pas
avant
merci beaucoup cécile de oliveira
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france avocate de la famille de steed
canis ommerciales